Hi Guys. Tim Ferriss here. Before we
get started, a quick announcements.
Have you ever wished that you could easily
access the best tips, tricks, tools,
and tactics, all that alliteration from
200 plus guests on the Tim Ferriss show,
that's about 600 to 700 hours of audio.
Well now you can,
and my new book tools
of titans does the job.
It is an inside look at my favorite
advice from the guests on the podcasts,
people like Arnold Schwarzenegger who
actually wrote the foreword for the book,
Jamie Foxx, Tony Robbins,
Peter Teal, Amanda Palmer,
and so many others and how you can apply
their wisdom to your life and how I've
applied all of their advice to
mine is at least 50% new material,
new tips from old guests,
new tips from brand new guests.
I poured my heart into this book.
So if you love the podcast,
you will love tools of titans.
Please check it out.
It helps me continue to do this podcast.
Pick up your copy or just read more
about it@toolsoftitans.com and as always,
thank you for listening.
Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking. Question,
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue.
This episode is brought
to you by four sigmatic.
I reached out to these innovative Finnish
entrepreneurs of all things because a
very skilled acrobat introduced
me to one of their products,
which is a mushroom coffee
made out of Chaga mushroom,
powerful antioxidant,
considered a super food.
I was introduced to Chaga
by Laird Hamilton of all
people and another mushroom
called lion's mane,
which is considered a no tropic or a
smart drug and I had half a packet and let
me put this in perspective. Tasted just
like coffee, just add the hot water,
only 20 milligrams in
half a packet of caffeine.
That's it's as little as one 10th what
you'd find in a strong cup of coffee and
I was on fire for the entire day.
I probably got more done in that day.
Then I got done in the three or four
days prior to that so I would highly
recommend checking it out. It is very
impressive. You will not see visuals,
so you can use it for work and you can
check it out@foursigmatic.com forward
slash Tim that's four Sigmatic,
s I g m a t I c.com forward slash Tim
and use the Code Tim to get 20% off your
first order.
I highly encourage you to try it out.
This episode is brought to
you by Wealthfront and this
is a very unique sponsor.
Wealthfront is a massively disruptive
in a good way, set it and forget it.
Investing service led by technologists
from places like apple and world famous
investors.
It has exploded in popularity in the last
two years and they have more than two
and a half billion dollars
under management. In fact,
some of my very good friends,
investors in silicon valley have millions
of their own money in Wealthfront.
So the question is why? Why is
it so popular? Why is it unique?
Because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them.
And this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations,
bloated sales teams, et cetera. And
I'll come back to that in a second.
I suggest you check out wealthfront.com
forward slash Tim take the risk
assessment quiz,
which only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they'd put you in and if
you just want to take their advice,
run with it, do it yourself.
You can do that or as I would,
you can set it and
forget it and here's why.
The value of Wealthfront is in the
automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a
regular basis but normally aren't.
Great investing is a marathon,
not a sprint,
and little things that you may or may
not be familiar with like automatic tax
loss harvesting,
rebalancing your portfolio,
cross more than 10 asset classes and
dividend reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods
of time. Wealthfront, as I mentioned,
since it's using software
instead of retail locations,
etc. Can offer all of this at low
costs that were previously completely
impossible right off the bat,
you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything.
They charge 0.25% per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free. If you use my link,
wealthfront.com forward slash Tim,
that is less than $5 a month to invest
a $30,000 account for instance. Now,
normally when I have a
sponsor on this show,
it's because I use them and
recommend them. In this case,
it's a little different.
I don't use Wealthfront yet because
I'm not allowed to. Here's the deal.
They wanted to sponsor this podcast,
but because of sec regulations,
companies that invest your money are
not allowed to use client testimonials.
So I couldn't be a user end
have them on the podcast,
but I've been so impressed by Wealthfront
that I've invested a significant
amount of my own money, at least for me,
uh, in the team and the company itself.
So I am an investor and hope
to soon use it as a client.
Now back to the recommendation
as a Tim Ferriss show listener,
you'll get $15,000 managed for free
if you decide to open an account.
But just start with seeing the portfolio
that they would suggest for you.
Take two minutes, fill out their
questionnaire@wealthfront.com
forward slash. Tim.
It's fast. It's free. There's
no downside that I can think of.
Little boys and girls, cats
and dogs, lemurs and squirrels.
This is Tim Ferriss and
welcome to another edition,
another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show
where it is my job to deconstruct world
class performers from all different
trades, all different specialties,
entertainment, military,
sports, you name it.
This episode is by request.
Thousands of you have been asking for
an episode on Dog Training and I would
expand that to human training.
How do you condition other people or
yourself to do what it is you want them or
you yourself to do.
This episode features Susan Garrett,
who is an incredible,
not only dog trainer but competitor.
She has a bachelor's of
science and animal science.
She's one of the most consistently
successful competitors in the sport of dog
agility.
For now more than two decades,
she's been on the podium of
world and national champion.
Let me try English again.
Championship events more than 50 times
winning those events a total of 38 times.
She was of great help to me.
When I first adopted Molly,
my own pup and her book
shaping success was voted,
are selected as the 2005 dog training
and behavior book of the year.
She is a champ both for her
competitive track record,
but also in her ability to convey
concrete tips and recommendations for,
for instance, the most critical games
and exercises to play with your dog.
The three types of reinforcement,
how do you as crates properly what you
should do in the first 24 hours of say,
adopting a puppy.
And we talk about just about every facet
of dog training and really the way you
should think of this as behavioral
modification and conditioning.
So the supplies to chickens,
it applies to maybe irritating inlaws
the cat that wants stopped sleeping on
your kitchen table. I think I borrowed
that from, don't shoot the dog,
but it's all the same thing.
So there are principles in this that
you can take away even if you have no
interest in training dog having
a dog or dogs in general.
So let's me then allow
Susan to do the talking.
You can find her on the Facebook
and she has a very active page,
lots of great pics and videos and that
is very simply facebook.com forward slash
Susan Garret, g a r r e t t,
Susan Garrett dog agility.
So facebook.com forward slash
Say Hi to her and I hope you enjoy
this conversation as much as I did.
Susan, welcome to the show.
Thanks Sam. Happy to be here.
I have wanted to get you on
the show for quite a while now.
After our first conversation,
I knew that we would eventually meet
again with recorded audio because my
audience has been asking me for an
episode on dog training and so on for ages
since I got Molly and
you and I spoke very,
very early on in that process for
me. Uh, the right when I was not,
I wouldn't say flatlining,
but kind of before I hockey sticked
in my training education and uh,
so I could think of no
better person to have on.
And a part of what appealed to me was
the fact that you have an objective and
verifiable record.
And what I mean by that,
and for those people who are
wondering how I seek out experts,
part of it is finding people who
can be evaluated objectively.
It's not their opinion, not someone
else's qualitative opinion. Uh,
you now I'm just going to
read a little bit of your bio.
I won't go into a ton of it,
but you are one of the most consistently
successful competitors in the sport of
dog agility over the past,
uh,
I guess at least two decades you've
been on the podium of world national
championship events more than 50 times
winning those events. A total of 38 times.
I was, I was hoping perhaps we
could start since most folks, well,
I shouldn't say most, but many folks
are not familiar with dog sports.
What is dog agility? What does,
what does that support look like?
Most people would have seen it
but maybe didn't know what it was.
We used to have a event on ESPN
a lot every year. So it's the,
it's a sport where the dogs go over the
Johnson through the tunnels and they
wave and out of the poles and it's
a really fast, fast sport. It's,
it's really gotten to a place where it's,
you know,
it's tough to keep up unless you're really
great shape as a handler that it's a
lot of convertibles,
dog and handler.
And what are some of the ways
in which that is scored? How,
how has that scored,
and I think we talked at one point,
maybe you and I talked
about this false starts.
Is that a big part of the or is
that a piece of the equation?
No, not in, in uh, agility. It definitely
isn't pliable, which is another sport.
I actually won world championships in
as well before I really got heavily
involved in and agility. Agility
is scored. Think of it like a,
if you watch a horse jumping competition,
not the Olympics at time is number one.
Um, but it has to be time with a clean
round. So there isn't style points.
It's just,
you know,
getting around over all the obstacles as
fast as you can without having a fault.
Hmm. And, uh, what,
what separates a good handler
from a great handler in,
let's just say for now, talking
about the, uh, the sport component?
Well, like any sport, the number one thing
that separates us is the mental game.
And once you take, put that
aside, it would be, um, the,
the DA, the handlers ability
to train their dog or,
and you can put an end or the
handlers ability to outrun their dog.
And most of my competition are in their
mid twenties and at the way the world
championship level.
So they are able to outrun their dog.
In my mid fifties. I am not,
uh, able to outrun any dog,
so I rely more on the dog training
aspect of it to be successful.
And what would you say differentiates
your approach to training compared to
others?
Uh,
for those people who have maybe only
seen a handful of like network TV shows
with celebrity dog trainers and so on.
I train,
I train dogs very much the way they did.
They trained marine mammals
or exotic animals. It's,
it's a reinforcement based program.
Think of it like a killer rally
can't get in the tank and,
and correct them and you know, beat the
crap out of them when they're wrong.
Right. To hit it with a
rolled up newspaper. Exactly.
So it's choice based dog training in,
in with the focus on reinforcement.
It's um,
it incredibly successful and that's
why, you know, when I raise a dog,
my focus is to have a phenomenal family
pet first and then I know that lays the
foundation to be a world champion later
and it's all done through, you know,
being intentional and
purposeful with what I want and,
and creating basically the dog of my
dreams every time I get a new puppy.
When you say what does that mean?
Choice based training?
There's basically, you know, if I,
if I was going to lump
training into three categories,
there would be punishment based,
which is more traditional because in the
military that's the way animals we're
often trained with. Um, you know, you're
the master and they will do it. They're,
they're told and there's really
no very little reinforcement.
It's the absence of punishment
that makes the dog keep working.
And it's the brilliance of dogs that
allows them to still have this great bond
with us in spite of what went on with
punishment based training and still goes
on because it's,
it's certainly not gone.
And then there's reinforcement based
training where people put a cookie on the
dog's nose and lower them to do, to
get what they want from them. And uh,
and that certainly is a step up
from punishment in that you're,
you're creating a relationship
of fun and trust. Uh,
it has its limitations on its
success once that lure is gone. And,
and then what we do is, is, uh,
different from that because we
definitely use food and toys and,
and anything the dog
loves as a reinforcement.
But it's only after the dog has made a
choice. So they make a choice and the,
you know, it's, it's like
consequence basically. You know,
I come from a family of nine kids and so,
and I never ever heard my
parents raised their voice.
So how you have success with that?
And this was really how I train my
first dog as I just modeled my mother.
And if we were upstairs watching
Disney and it was, you know,
five to six and they called us for supper,
they didn't yell and stamp their
feet and you know, carry on.
They would give us a chance to make
a choice. Are you coming for supper?
And if you,
if you choose not to come down for supper,
then she would go into the basement,
unscrew the fuse for the TV and there'd
be no TV for the rest of the night and
for the next 24 hours.
So you have the choice to either
do as you're asked or not.
And you live by the consequences of that
choice. And that's pretty much, you know,
how we raise the dogs.
You create an environment
rich and reinforcement so
that the correct choice when
you want them to make is the
one they end up wanting to make.
But if they choose something
that isn't what you want,
the environment controls the consequences
so that you don't have to punish them
or beat up or the rolled up
newspaper would be a good example.
Dog Training. I mean, and the
story of the TV brings to mind a
video I watched of you actually, uh,
believe it was helping to train a woman's
dog with leave it and covering the
food. I think you were covering
the food with your hand.
Could you explain if that's a good
example? I don't know if it is,
but could you explain how that works?
Yeah, that's one of our
foundational games. So we have
four games. We tell people,
you know, you can rock it with your
dog if you get these four games in.
And the first one is the one you
described, it's called, it's your choice.
That's why I created my own word. And
it's just one word. It's your choice.
And we want the dogs to know you're
in control of all the good things that
happen in your life.
And,
and it's just a response
cost of me closing my hand
around the food. So, you know,
you get a handful of really attractive
traits and depending on the dog's food
drive, like if it was, uh, you know,
a sight hound dog that doesn't have a
ton of food drive, I might get like,
you know, the, the top level value food,
I could get steak and cheese and put
that in my hand. And if it was a,
a Chow Hound, you know, like a Labrador,
they just love food or a Sheltie you
could put cable in your hand and the dog's
gonna like Paul and bite
and bark and go crazy.
They're going to be on a leash so that
they don't have access to just go find
something else to do. But as soon as
they stop all that, you open your hand.
It's your choice.
So your choice was to stop unwanted
behavior and my choice was to open my hand
and then the dog says, Hey, party
on, I'm going to dive into the food.
Well I didn't like that choice,
so I'm going to close my hand.
And this goes back and forth like a
tennis match until the dogs choice is just
to sit back and stare at
the hand when it's open.
And then I pick up a
cookie and I feed them.
And that's the first communication
that's clear to that dog.
I am in control of the good things in
my life because if I do what this person
wants,
good things happen.
And that's the premise for absolutely
everything we do. Whether, you know,
I have students who train animals at the
Toronto Zoo and it's exactly the same
premise that you,
you control access to the reinforcement
and then you reward good choices by
giving access to reinforcement.
And the thing is with dog owners
and they don't realize, you know,
when we think about reinforcement,
they think,
well I've got to go cut up some cheese
because I'm training my dog. But there,
there's really, you know, there's,
there's three really big reinforcements
for our dogs. It's the food is obvious.
Toys you throw a ball or a Frisbee,
that's obvious, but it's the hidden ones,
the ones that aren't so obvious. Those
are the ones that get people into trouble.
So it's permission to do things.
So if you're going to the park and
your dogs pulling you on a leash and,
and they're chasing a squirrel
and you and you like, okay,
I got to get rid of this, I'm going
to have to take the leash off. So,
and the dog gets his massive reward
of getting to chase a squirrel.
But what you've just
done with the permission,
you've rewarded what behavior you don't
want. Exactly. Pulling on a leash.
So that goes all day long.
And it's,
and it's when you have an awakening too,
where's w we told our
students where's the value?
Where's the value for the dog right now?
And if you'd have an unwanted behavior,
like pulling on leash, you've got to say,
okay, here's what I want.
Let's just get clear.
This is be real intentional
about this is what I want,
this is what it's going to look like.
This is what I've got.
So what's between there is a
gap of what I have to train.
And the first thing to identify is where's
the value for the dog? Because dogs,
they just do what's reinforcing.
And you just identify where
that reinforcement is and
start to control it in a
way that you give them
permission for what they want.
So when we go back to that
dog pulling on a leash,
you might stand still until the dog came
in beside you and then praise them so
that they connect, oh, my action gave
me the access to be free and chase.
So you make that connection that all the
value comes through you and you become
part of the process instead of the dog.
And the squirrel being the only two people
in the process for two animals in the
process.
And uh, this is, I'm, it's,
it's been a little bit since I was digging
really deep in a lot of these videos,
which were fantastic. But
is that a, do you call it,
I think in this particular
case, the sort of, um,
common heel position, like the dog to
your left and then the reward zone,
is that the right,
right,
exactly. Reinforcement zone over reward
zone. And if that's what you think of it,
that all good things in life
happen right there. And again,
pulling on leash is such a pain
in the butt for so many people,
but they don't realize that.